la minute d'amour du centre commercial
place d'armes
[Musique]
mamie la solution pour toi ma mi to
bottom ami tu es la plus belle femme du
monde
je t'aime à me masser au qui est maman
que demande le peuple
on a envoyé besoins des gens c'est une
bonne fête à ma vie à maman à moi aussi
mes émotions tout raté la meilleure la
maman la plus forte
tu as les mesures fortes si on est
parfait comme tu dis souvent temps dette
mais sans nous tu fais quoi tu t'ennuies
à la maison elle voit la bombe et on
t'aime et puis il reste comme tu ne
changes pas vraiment une âme en forme je
t'aime maman
même si je tombe je t'aime et continue
avec un petit peu aussi était maman j'ai
cette maman
vraiment je t'aime de tout mon coeur tu
es la plus belle de toutes les mendiants
l'internât mangez-vous reprennent maman
je vous souhaite une bonne fête des
mères et je profite de l'occasion pour
souhaiter une bonne fête des mères à
toutes les mamans surtout celles qui
souffrent ceux qui sont malades celles
qui sont à l'hôpital et je vous souhaite
bonne fête de tout mon coeur et bisous à
tous je voulais te dire en fait parce
que c'est très gentil ce que tu m'as
tous les jours que tu puisse mener à
l'école tous les matins et que tu
puisses et que tu puisse m'offrir plein
de cadeaux et puis moi aussi je voudrais
te fais plein de cadeaux parce que tu es
la meilleure maman du monde pour moi et
tu seras toujours là dans mon coeur
bonne fête maman je souhaite une bonne
fête à toutes les mamans de la
martinique et dans le monde entier est
une cause penser à ma maman qui n'est
plus de ce monde et qu'il avait à mon
coeur
bonjour c'était pour passer un message à
maman chérie et je voulais lui dire que
je laime qu'elle est gentil belle et que
je lui souhaite une bonne fête des mères
c'est tout je souhaite une très bonne
fête des mères à toutes les mamans de
martinique notamment à ma femme qui est
maire et à toutes les mamans de la
caraïbe
bonne fête maman bonjour à tous
j'aimerais dire merci à ma maman pour
tout ce qu'elle fait pour moi pour ma
réussite et j'aimerais dire à toutes les
mamans qui élèvent leurs enfants seuls
bon courage et
ma mère aussi du calme élève seule donc
bonne fête maman et à toutes les mamans
maman d'où tous époux phuc a chanté mon
manteau tournon précaire
oubliez toutes les choses c'est fait on
a ajouté nous rassembler pour que ça
dure mais aussi bonne fête maman la
minute d'amour vous a été présentée par
le centre commercial place d'armes